yes the judge has now uh handed down his
judgment he has said that the
application is refused that flights will
go ahead they can go ahead and that
flight that is due to depart from the uk
to rwanda on tuesday will depart and
that means that the 30 plus asylum
seekers who are supposed to be on board
will be heading to east africa um but
what it doesn't mean though is that
there won't be a judicial review because
that application was lodged a few days
ago on wednesday actually by various
claimants that may still go ahead
this will be a blow a big blow for
campaigners because they were arguing
that the policy was unlawful and that
people would be left potentially
stranded out in rwanda in a country
where their asylum claims weren't going
to be processed in a fair way
they had argued that seven days the
seven days given to asylum seekers once
they're given notice of what's called a
removal direction wasn't long enough for
them to uh to be able to to launch their
own objections to it
the unhcr as well the un's refugee
agency as well
their
lawyer stood up in court today and
backed those claimants saying as well
that they didn't think that there was a
fair system out there there was no
evidence and they actually said that
despite claims to the country they
hadn't been involved with the uk
government
with regards to the rwandan arrangement
and they weren't endorsing it either
this is a policy that has been described
in the past as a cruel and nasty policy
uh it's been described by justin welby
the archbishop of canterbury as ungodly
but for the government there's a lot
riding on this they hope that this is
the answer to their uh immigration
issues they want to be seen to be tough
on immigration bear in mind that since
the start of this year more than ten
thousand asylum seekers have made that
dangerous journey across the channel to
get to the uk um it was just a few weeks
ago that the prime minister said that
you know despite these claims that
rwanda um wasn't necessarily a safe
place or the best place for these people
to be sent he said that rwanda had been
totally transformed in recent years so
we what we will be seeing is that asylum
seekers will be headed to rwanda there
are more flights that will be scheduled
in the next
probably a few weeks maybe
and they will go ahead too the
government has clarified though that at
the moment they are looking at single
lone people to send out they're not
families but in future
they will be looking to send families to
rwanda as well to have their asylum
applications processed and their whole
argument for all of this was in the
public interest they say
because they want to deter people from
making those unnecessary illegal and
dangerous crossings um
the just yesterday downing street said
that the prime minister was confident
that the flights would go ahead uh they
are committed politically to pursuing uh
this policy of course pretty patel as
well they want to be as i say tough on
immigration but this isn't the fir the
last legal challenge rather this is just
the first of many on monday we've also
heard from asylum aid another charity
that they will be putting forward their
own legal objections potentially another
injunction application and of course
more individuals are putting forward
their
own claims as well so it's certainly the
not it's not the last that we've heard
uh with regards to legal challenges on
this but just quickly adele on the the
flight itself on tuesday as you said
there's more legal challenges to come
there's even another court case in the
high court to be heard on monday but the
flight that's due to go on tuesday now
goes definitely or could the case is due
on monday affect that
as it stands it's going ahead um
anything can happen i suppose between
now then because as i said more legal
challenges can be mounted but i would
say that it's a bit too late in the day
unless there are some new legal
arguments
that they come up with on monday
they are going ahead um
i'm just hearing more from inside court
the judge has granted applicants leave
to appeal
and he says that he believes that
provisions have been made for the court
of appeal to have to hear it on monday
so that's probably going to be the next
step in all of this he's also said that
a judicial review a full hearing should
be able to go ahead before the end of
july and that will be to look into more
detail as to whether this policy is
unlawful um but in the meantime as i
said those asylum seekers will be going
to rwanda